the girl in the spider's web is the
latest in the Dragon Tattoo franchise
this time starring Claire Foy as
Elizabeth previously played by Rooney
Mara and before that in their original
Swedish film new mera Paz this film
follows Lisbeth as she runs away from
computer hackers and government people
because there's an evil program that can
launch nuclear weapons and missiles
everywhere and blow up the whole planet
a little bit of history about myself I
really love the Dragon Tattoo films
especially the original new mera Paz is
still to this day even after seeing this
film my favorite Lisbeth I think she was
brilliant so good and I really like
David Fincher's film too and Rooney Mara
and Daniel Craig the two original
sequels weren't as good but I did like
them and especially the extended which I
have here which if you ever want to
watch the extended I would recommend
that it's a very enlightening experience
there's a lot of stuff they took out of
those movies and naturally I was a bit
disappointed that they weren't
continuing what Fincher brought up and
Sony decided to just go in a whole new
different direction instead of financing
the continuation of what he so
brilliantly started and now we have a
new version of Lisbeth directed by a new
filmmaker based off of a story that was
not in the original authors and so you
know it's alright it's it's kind of a
James Bond movie
it's sort of like they're trying to make
it more of an action film like there's a
scene where she's on a motorcycle and
she explodes off of this dock and lands
on a frozen pond and just drives off on
a frozen pond without breaking through
the ice and the tires have perfect tread
it felt very much like a die another day
scene kind of stuck in the middle of a
Dragon Tattoo movie which these films to
me have always been very hard-edged and
very gritty you feel almost dirty when
you're watching it you're supposed to
feel kind of filthy these stories have a
lot of darkness behind them and while
this film does in hints that's about as
far as it goes a hint this film feels
considerably watered down safer and more
sanitized than the original films it's
definitely a film that will appeal to
more mass
market tendencies in America it's better
as a franchise starter in that case
because Lizbeth has become more of a
superhero and less of an actual human
being and so I understand what Sony's
trying to do the David Fincher's film
didn't make as much money as they wanted
it to and it took all of this time to
make another one so instead of just
going forth with a really gritty and
realistic portrayal that people seem to
really like we now have a considerably
more fun movie where the audience can go
yeah a lot and that's not what I want to
see I want to go to one of these movies
and I want to leave feeling sad I want
to feel cold I want to see nastiness and
that's not to say the film doesn't have
dark themes there are certainly things
mentioned where you think that's
disgusting and I feel bad for those
characters because that happened to them
it's just that it doesn't go the places
the other films did we're supposed to
progress you know we're supposed to push
the boundaries especially as we
continued down the line of all these
different versions of these movies but
instead they're almost retracting and
and becoming closer to almost a really
hard edge pg-13 Claire Foy is good as
Lizabeth I think she gave a lot of
conviction to this role and she
certainly is not the problem with the
movie neither is director fede alvarez
who I loved don't breathe I really liked
his Evil Dead remake too I bought both
of those I think he's a super super
talented director and this is a visually
stunning movie it's really just the
story and the direction the characters
have been taken and while I don't really
see Claire for giving a bad performance
I think she's really talented this is
easily my least favorite portrayal of
Elisabeth knew Mira Paz still being the
best I mean she did so much of the stunt
work Rooney Mara pierced her entire body
I mean there's so much dedication that
has been given to this role and this
portrayal of her felt more like a
superhero which I have already said this
film seems to think that Lisbeth is cool
because she's a super hacker and because
she can look into a camera lens and go
mmm I did it I hacked your system and I
wear
black clothes and this film like
mistakes Lisbeth as that like that's why
would you like her no we like her
because of what she's been through and
because she doesn't give a and this
movie certainly has moments like that
this isn't to say this is a bad
necessarily portrayal of her it just
didn't feel as real as the past two so
good performances good direction but a
very lackluster story and a poor
direction that could fall on the
producers or the studio for these
characters Mikael Blomkvist is also in
the film and he has barely any purpose
of being there besides we have to have
him in the movie his character feels
very pointless and super inconsequential
to the plot he also looked younger than
Lisbeth which is weird like that's not
the character there was so much about
him that was wrong in the movie the
actor is fine
it's just what they did with the
characters I'm gonna give the girl in
the spider's web a C+ guys thank you so
much as always for watching look forward
to more reviews coming very soon this
weekend if you like this you can click
right here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]